everything you said about the
military-industrial complex is true
right and it's been we've been worrying
about that on both sides of the aisle
for a very long time I mean that's just
that phrase came from from Eisenhower
um
it's uh
I mean so much of
what ails us is a story of bad
incentives right and bad incentives are
so powerful
that they corrupt even good people right
how much more do they corrupt bad people
right like so it's like you want to at
minimum you want reasonably good people
at least non-pathological people in Us
in the system
trying to navigate against the grain of
bad incentives and better still
all of us can get together and try to
diagnose those incentives and change
them right and and and we will really
succeed when we have a system of
incentives where
the the good incentives are so strong
that even bad people are effortlessly
behaving as though they're good people
because they're so successfully
incentivized to behave that way right
that's you know and so so it's it's
almost the inversion of our current
situation so yes
and you say I changed my mind about the
war
I not quite I mean I I was never a
supporter of the war in Iraq I was
always worried that it was a distraction
from the war in Afghanistan I was a
supporter of the war in Afghanistan and
I will admit in hindsight that looks
like uh
you know at best a highly ambiguous and
painful exercise you know more likely a
Fool's errand right I was like that
would you know it did not turn out well
it's it's
it wasn't for want of trying I I don't
you know I have not done a deep dive on
on all of the failures there and maybe
all of these failures or failures in
principle I mean maybe it's just maybe
that's not the kind of thing that can be
done well by anybody whatever our
intentions
um but yeah the move to Iraq always
seemed questionable to me and um
when we knew the problem the immediate
problem at that moment you know Al Qaeda
uh uh was in Afghanistan and you know
and then bouncing to Pakistan
um
anyway all you know so yes but my
my sense of the possibility of nation
building my sense of of
you know and so insofar as the the the
neocon
um
Spirit of of uh
you know responsibility and idealism
that you know America was the kind of
nation that should be functioning in
this way as as the world's cop and we've
got we have to get in there and and
untangle some of these knots by force um
uh rather often because
you know if we don't do it over there
we're gonna have to do it over here kind
of thing
um yeah some of that has definitely
changed for me in my thinking
I mean there are obviously cultural
reasons why it failed in Afghanistan and
if you can't change the culture
um it's uh
you're not going to force a change at
gunpoint in the culture or it certainly
seems that that's not going to happen
and it took us you know over 20 years to
apparently to realize that that's one of
the things you realize with the war is
there's not going to be a strong signal
that things are not working you can just
keep pouring money into a thing a
military effort well also there are
signs of it working too you have all the
stories of girls now going to school
right you know the girls are getting
battery acid thrown in their faces by
religious maniacs and then we come in
there and we stop that and now girls are
getting educated and there's a and
that's all good and our intentions are
good there and we're on the right side
of history there good girls should be
going to school you know Malala Joseph
Sai should have the Nobel Prize and she
shouldn't have been shot in the face by
by the Taliban right
um
we know what the right answers are there
the question is what do you do when
there are enough in this particular case
religious Maniacs who are willing to die
and let their children die in defense of
crazy ideas and moral Norms that belong
in the 7th century
um
and it's a problem we couldn't solve and
we couldn't solve it even though we
spent you know trillions of dollars to
solve it